an aids muss heute niemand mehr sterben
und es gibt ein medikament gegen die
immunschwächekrankheit der haken bisher
das medikament war einfach nahezu
unbezahlbar und das hat sich jetzt
dramatisch geändert
ob und wie es jetzt aufgehalten werden
kann und wie es vor allem mit der hiv
impfung steht jetzt in klink vom science
fiction herzlich willkommen
die zahl die es wirklich heftig
schätzungsweise sind bisher wohl 35
millionen menschen an der
immunschwächekrankheit hiv gestorben
doch der plan gegen die therapierbare
aber immer noch unheilbare erkrankung
ist klar
bis 2020 soll das zunächst einmal das 90
90 90 ziel seien langfristig geht es
dann darum aids komplett auszurotten und
zwar bereits zum jahr 2030 fangen wir
mal mit einer guten nachricht an die
kosten für hiv therapien sind in den
letzten jahren enorm gesunken etwa 80
dollar kostet jetzt ein jahr therapie
das ist im vergleich zu der ersten
antiretroviralen therapie gegen hiv
nichts pro patient und jahr waren
nämlich damals satte 15.000 us dollar zu
zahlen kaum jemand konnte das geld
aufbringen und nicht weniger schlimm für
die erkrankten war dass sie pro tag an
die zwanzig verschiedene medikamente
nehmen muss mittlerweile haben
betroffene die eine therapie erhalten
eine normale lebenserwartung dazu kommt
wird die erkrankung frühzeitig behandelt
schützt sie zu 96% auch vor einer
hiv-übertragung so gesehen hat die
forschung tatsächlich viel erreicht und
auch der gesellschaftliche umgang mit
dem thema hat sich enorm verbessert
mittlerweile herrscht weltweit eine
wirklich große solidarität im kampf
gegen aids und das ist auch gut so
michael sidibé leitet das aids programm
der vereinten nationen un hat vor kurzem
ein interview mit dem tagesspiegel
spiegel geführt und dachte gesagt zitat
der schulterschluss zwischen politik
zivilgesellschaft und wissenschaft hat
nicht nur die krankheit selbst in die
zange genommen sondern noch etwas ganz
anderes bewirkt alle menschen haben ein
recht auf den zugang zu medikamenten
heute können wir zum ersten mal sagen
dass mehr hiv infizierte mit einer
therapie leben als ohne insgesamt werden
demnach knapp 21 millionen von knapp 37
millionen hiv erkrankten mit der
sogenannten antiretroviralen therapie
versorgt ein noch krassere vergleich vor
knapp 18 jahren wurden in südafrika 90
menschen behandelt heutzutage sind es
vier millionen und die ziele für die
nächsten jahre sind
die große vision eine welt komplett
unaids und das solle in zwei schritten
erreicht werden bis zum jahr 2020 und
das ist ja nicht mehr lang hin soll das
90 90 90 ziel erreicht werden 90 prozent
sollen ihren hiv status kennen 90
prozent sollen zugang zu therapien haben
und weitere 90 prozent sollen eine virus
last unter der nachweisgrenze haben 2014
haben die vereinten nationen das aids
projekt un aids ins leben gerufen und im
september 2015 war es dann zumindest in
einem land soweit schweden hat als
erstes land die 90 90 90 zähler erreicht
in deutschland könnte eine pille zur
prävention dazu beitragen nachzuziehen
seit 2016 gibt es die sogenannte prä
exposition prophylaxe wie sie im
medizinische fachsprache genannt wird in
der szene wird sie einfach nur prep
genannt die die sie nennen sind die
sogenannten treffer vor allem unter den
homosexuellen sind sie beliebt und wird
diese gruppe schon fast etwas so etwas
wie eine sexuelle revolution geworden
denn sie sorgt für sorgenfreies ex die
beiden wirkstoffe tenofovir und
emtricitabin sollen dafür sorgen dass
sich der hi virus nicht vermehren kann
das sind übrigens genau dieselben
wirkstoffe die bei hiv-positiven den
ausbruch der krankheit verhindern sollen
2015 zeigten unter anderem zwei große
studien aus europa dass die pille
tatsächlich vor einer hiv-infektion
schützen kann
in beiden studien lag der schutz bei 86
war und er würde wahrscheinlich bei rund
100 prozent liegen wenn das medikament
richtig eingenommen würde man muss sie
nämlich mindestens fünf tage vor dem
ungeschützten verkehr ab diesem tag wo
sollen sie jeden tag einnehmen
und ja das wäre würde dann bedeuten dass
die pille hiv komplett austrocknen
könnte kritiker dagegen warnen durch die
pille werden mehr geschlechtskrankheiten
übertragen wie tripper syphilis und so
weiter der grund risikogruppen wiegen
sich in falscher sicherheit und
benutzten seltener kondome dennoch gab
es vor allem in den letzten monaten
einen regelrechten boom
um diese pille gegen hiv denn seit
oktober 2017 kostet sie noch
nur noch 51 euro im monat vorher waren
es rund 800 euro um die 90 90 90 ziele
weltweit zu schaffen muss aber noch mehr
passieren hiv test beispielsweise
müssten zu einer selbstverständlichkeit
werden
das ist vor allem in manchen südlichen
teil von afrika noch nicht der fall weil
sich die männer dort nicht testen lassen
sind 80 prozent der neu infizierten
jugendlichen mädchen anders dagegen
sieht es im afrikanischen staat zwar
zeeland aus dass 90 90 90 ziel ist
bereits jetzt erreicht noch vor fünf
jahren herrschte hier die höchste
infektionsrate weltweit vor allem die
intensive aufklärungsarbeit hat hier
wunder gewirkt für die nächste zeit
stehen hier vor allem die themen bildung
und sexualerziehung auf dem tippzettel
die zahl der hiv-infizierten könnte
sinken wenn vor allem die mädchen die
schule zu ende bringen könnten und das
ist finanziell nicht wirklich ein
mammutprojekt lediglich zehn dollar pro
kopf im monat werden dafür veranschlagt
zudem könnte afrika auch geholfen werden
wenn das land eigene medikamente
produzieren könnte eben diese bei denen
der patentschutz schon abgelaufen ist
mit ganz anderen problemen
dagegen haben die region in zentralasien
und osteuropa zu kämpfen dort ist die
zahl der neuinfektionen seit 2010 um
mehr als die hälfte gestiegen ein
großteil davon macht russland aus zudem
gibt es einen weiteren negativtrend auch
die zahl derjenigen die an aids sterben
nimmt zu das liegt unter anderem daran
dass die betroffenen dort ihre krankheit
nicht kommunizieren um hilfe zu bekommen
viele von ihnen werden diskriminiert sie
sind häufig homosexuell transgender
drogenabhängige oder prostituierte
russland hätte das potential aids bis
2030 endgültig zu bekämpfen doch dafür
müsste entschieden gegen die
stigmatisierung vorgegangen werden ein
sehr großes problem weltweit aber auch
in deutschland ist die zunehmende
gleichgültigkeit es gibt studien nach
denen es vor allem die sehr jungen
menschen sind die sich nicht mehr
schützen und das könnte tatsächlich dazu
führen dass die welt in zukunft
weiterhin mit es zurecht kommen muss das
robert koch institut schreibt in seinem
epidemiologischen bulletin vom november
2017 dass die strategie zur eindämmung
von hiv weiter konsequent umgesetzt
werden sollte
insbesondere durch eine weitere
verbesserung der test angebote und die
gewährleistung des zugangs zur therapie
für alle in deutschland von hiv
betroffenen menschen inklusive der
menschen ohne krankenversicherung eine
weitere idee sind selbst tests für zu
hause da verspricht sich zum beispiel
die deutsche aids-hilfe aus denn das
könnte den schritt erleichtern überhaupt
einen hiv test zu machen andere sehen
das kritisch weil dabei natürlich die
ärztliche beratung fehlt in deutschland
dürfen solche selbst setzen noch nicht
abgegeben werden auch in anderen
europäischen ländern wie den
niederlanden ist das möglich immer mal
wieder gibt es ja auch meldungen zu
einer möglichen aids impfung doch in den
letzten jahrzehnten habe es nur sehr
wenige von ihnen bis in die letzte
studienphase geschafft keiner davon ist
bislang auf dem markt fleisch ist ja
auch dass nur noch eine frage der zeit
doch darauf ausruhen sollten wir uns
nicht dazu michelle sidibé
ich glaube an die impfung aber sie wird
hiv nicht auslöschen eine impfung wird
niemals hundertprozentig schützen
auch wenn sie etliche infektionen
verhindern könnte seiner meinung nach
sei es wichtig an ganz vielen fronten zu
kämpfen und zwar wie schon gesagt
beispielsweise zugang zu bildung und
wissen schaffen und die diskriminierung
von aids patienten und patientinnen
bekämpfen wenn ihr kein video zu diesem
thema und auch zu allen anderen dem
verpassen wollt dann tut mehr ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den genau
auf die glocke
denn nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über
neue videos informiert hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken eine
krankheit schlimmer als aids ja
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran